the intertribal church choir youth mama
sinks for peace between South Sudan's
ethnic groups it has members from all
the major tribes and things in different
languages to spread its message it's a
much needed task but sometimes politics
get in the way we have tried 64 tribes
when my dream was to bring two people
together not politician they did they
will not bring people together the other
people the work of the group has never
been easy throughout the country's
conflict-ridden history but now there is
a new hurdle a recent decree by
President Salva Kiir is to create 28
states largely along tribal lines
instead of learning to get along and
build a national identity tribes will be
administered separately the decree has
been well received by many of the Dinka
community in Bor the capital of Jonglei
state where youth mama was founded this
think a tribal chief is arbitrating
issues of Katherine between tribes and
hopes the new states will reduce into
tribal clashes una nope Alana well if
you could mean ever now say thinks it
will bring peace because it will solve a
leadership problem hmm I usually
everyone can become the leader in his or
her own area the people who are not from
here we'll go back to their own state
that of unit but others fear that
redrawing the state boundaries could
give rise to new tensions a few
kilometers outside of Bor around 2,300
and we're still shelter at the UN base
afraid to come out the new states are
not making it easier lon where you will
be living here in this area I either
more or Duke all of them they will go
back to their hunt state and then this
is seem to be a decentralization and
when you look at it also it is
at decentralization it is tribalism the
conflict has left deep scars between
ethnic groups entangled in the midst of
a political struggle church groups such
as youth mama are perhaps the only ones
who can bridge the divide because among
the people there are good people and
there are bad people but these good
people you can bring them together and
then connect people good all of them but
if tribes are secluded the opportunities
for interaction and hence reconciliation
might be few and far between